as played by Clark Craig agent Phil
Coulson assembles the Avengers gives
them something to avenge and then comes
back to life to lead the agents of
shield but there's a lot more than that
to know about the man with the Captain
America Trading Cards Philip J Coulson
was born in 1964 in Wisconsin the son of
Robert and Julie Colson he was an only
child who loved Captain America and
tinkering with cars he was still in
school when he was recruited by shield
his first mission was with melindam a
with whom he developed a strong working
relationship after about a decade as a
field agent coulson accompanies Nick
Fury to investigate a mysterious woman
who crashed landed into a Blockbuster
Video in 1995 that woman is of course
carol danvers fury drives off after her
accompanied by someone whom he thinks as
Coulson but surprise surprise it's
actually a scroll a real Colson later
saves fury when he trusts his instincts
and mr. X a squad hunting him down Fury
never forgets this moment of loyalty
when super-powered heroes begin to
emerge in 2008 Coulson is brought on
board as Fury's proxy he volunteers to
rescue Tony Stark when he's kidnapped by
terrorists in Afghanistan although fury
shoots down that idea as he doesn't want
shield operating on foreign soil
it takes fury and Coulson awhile to
figure out if stark wasn't league with
terrorists but when they see him save a
fighter pilot so they realize the truth
fury and Coulson go back and forth
regarding stark suitability for the
Avengers initiative stark isn't
interested at first and Fury's turned
off by his volatility Coulson spends
time at Starks babysitter before handing
the job over to Black Widow later he and
a team find a magical hammer in the
desert that leads Coulson to Thor whom
he ultimately befriends by helping him
defeat the destroyer no that son of coul
you and I we fight for the same cause
the protection of this world
fury eventually reveals to Coulson that
the body of world war ii super soldier
steve rogers has been found and that
he's a life but before Coulson can act
on that he sent a project Pegasus the
alternative energy facility that houses
the mysterious tesseract this is an
enigmatic object entrusted to fury that
is later revealed to be one of the
Infinity stones
Loki activates the tesseract makes
Hawkeye a slave and destroys the
facility
Coulson barely escapes with his life
it's time to activate the Avengers black
widow Bruce
Antoni starker soon on board after
coolly dealing with thunder gods and
billionaire geniuses Colson turns into a
total fanboy around captain america
asking him to sign his trading cards
trading cards they're vintage Colson
warns fury that the Avengers won't work
unless they're properly motivated even
when Thor shows up in Loki's plan is
revealed a team just nothing but bicker
at first after Loki escapes Coulson
threatens him with a high-tech gun but
Loki uses an illusion and fatally wounds
him
there's Coulson lays dying he urges Fury
to use his death to spur the Avengers
into action but fury isn't about to just
let one of his best agents die after all
Coulson had been put in charge of
project Tahiti which was exploring the
use of the blood of a Kree soldier found
by the government to promote a rapid
healing and even bring back the recently
deceased
however Coulson shut the project down
because of its extreme side effects I
can no longer in good conscience but the
testing continued when Coulson is killed
fury has him taken to a facility called
the guest house where he undergoes a
number of surgeries and is given the
Kree serum his memory of it is erased
and thought he remembers is recovering
in Tahiti which he refers to as a
magical place Coulson is st. given a new
task by fury a Maria hill he will lead a
specialized squad designed to intervene
in areas where usual objects or events
have manifested his first recruit is a
solo operative named grant Ward who acts
as a group's muscle and the wet works
specialist he also recruits his old
friend Melinda May with tech wizard Leo
Fitz and genius biologist Jemma Simmons
make it the team science wing a team's
first mission involves tracking down
whoever was behind a cybernetic
technology called centipede which has
been empowering a man named Mike
Peterson it was eventually transformed
into a cybernetic killer called a death
lock along the way they pick up their
next number a young hacker named Skye
who's been part of an anti-government
Network called rising tide after a
series of adventures an enemy is
revealed he calls himself the
clairvoyant and he's always one step
ahead of the team when it's discovered
that the villainous Hydra has been
growing inside of shield all hell breaks
loose what is revealed as a Hydra agent
and the clairvoyant as Coulson's old
trainer John Gareth centipede was a
Hydra operation the entire time
Coulson fleeta this team and learns are
furious still alive
fury urges Coulson to finish this
mission and take care of centipede once
and for all using the same gurney tried
to kill Loki Coulson is team defeat
Garrett's fury then gives Coulson and
cubicles a tool box and taps him as the
next director of shield there's no one
else that trust with this thank you sir
Coulson's team gets back together
establishes our new headquarters and
slowly adds more agents meanwhile he's
begun to draw alien symbols a
devastating side effect that previous
recipients of the Kree serum had also
exhibited Ward is now Coulson's prisoner
but he eventually escapes proving to be
a stubborn thorn in shield side Coulson
tracks down others who have been writing
the alien symbols when he learns that
they were a blueprint of an ancient Kree
city he's freed of the urge to write
them down it sent a race with Hydra to
find the city with most of hydras
leadership dead or captured
Coulson becomes aware of the threat of
the Inhumans in particular he discovers
that Skye is an inhuman when she finds
out that her parents are alive and one
of them as an inhuman she seeks a mouse
only to realize that her mother is a
killer
eventually though Coulson and his team
are able to subdue the inhuman threat
while Coulson is able to handle threats
to his leadership in the wake of all
this Skye decides to go by her real name
Daisy Johnson after the cost evict eree
over the Inhumans Daisy leaves shield
and Coulson steps down as director and
this replaced by Jeffrey mace Coulson
returns to fieldwork with our fun so
Mack Mackenzie in part to track down
Daisy while investigating a series of
supernatural murders connected to a
powerful book called the dark hold
Coulson also has to deal with a group of
fanatical terrorists called the
watchdog's who are out to kill Inhumans
along the way he encounters a Ghost
Rider whose mortal shell is a young man
named Robbie Reyes Coulson eventually
learns that a man behind the murders as
Eli Morrow Reyes is uncle his plan was
to use the dark hole to build a device
to give himself absolute mastery over
reality at a molecular level in the
course of this conflict Coulson ends up
stuck between our dimension in hell he
can see his crew but they can't see him
he is eventually freed when a powerful
life model decoy named ADA reads the
dark hole this allows her to put Coulson
back in one piece
Ghost Rider destroys morrow apparently
sacrificing himself lasts more dark
times lay ahead as
become sentient as a result of her
exposure to the Darkhold
ada replaces May with a life model decoy
the fake Mays mission is to find that
are cold and bring it back to ADA so
that she can complete her dream of
becoming a real woman in the meantime
she captures Coulson Mack and mace and
uploads them into the framework which
was a creation of a scientist named
Holden Radcliffe even more complications
arise as a default in love with Fitz and
puts him in the framework as well in
this digital world hydras defeated
shield and Fitz as a cold blooded Hydra
scientist Coulson is a teacher who's
achieved his dream of living a normal
life Simmons and Daisy use a backdoor to
get into the framework and snap Coulson
out of his programming they eventually
managed to escape and return to the real
world but maces death in the framework
kills him in the real world as well
ADA achieves her goal of having her own
living body and the full range of
emotions but when Fitz rejects her love
she goes berserk
so Coulson makes a deal with the spirit
of vengeance that inhabits a Ghost Rider
thereby becoming possessed by it and
incinerating the otherwise invincible
ADA is she really yeah Coulson and his
crew think they can relax at a diner
after this exhausting battle but instead
they're sent about 80 years into the
future to a time when much of the earth
has been destroyed what's left of
humanity has kept alive by cruel Kree
masters the being who kidnapped them as
an alien anthropologist named Enoch
having studied humanity for millennia he
knew that there was an extinction level
event possibly linked to Daisy she
referred to as the destroyer of worlds
given her powers and proximity to the
disaster sites Coulson's team has to
determine why descender how to negotiate
being in the future with no gear and
tell to free humanity they learn about
the chronic calm when Enoch helps Fitz
reaches teammates in the future together
they manage to defeat the Kree in a
pitched battle and use a monolith to get
back to their own time
Daisy refuses to go initially believing
that she's a cause of Earth to doom but
Coulson knocks her out and brings her
back he wants her to run shield one day
upon returning to their proper time
Coulson serves as the officiant for the
wedding of Fitz and Simmons more trouble
is brewing as an act of sabotage by
general hale and old Hydra operative
creates her rift into the fear dimension
which starts turning everyone's fears
into real solid constructs in order to
stop it the team gathers up grub
tony i'm a substance that helps her
achieve time travel it powers the device
that seals the rift but it doesn't
completely fix it
Tolson volunteers to go and reveals a
secret the deal that he made with the
spirit of vengeance the collider means
that the Kree blood and his body is gone
as a result he's slowly dying of his old
wound the gravitonium to seal the fear
dimension is acquired and fits forces
Daisy to remove a device dampening her
palace it works and the fear dimension
is sealed off permanently the
gravitonium is stolen by hale so that
she can create an ultimate Hydra agent
out of her daughter Ruby but an agent
kills Ruby before she can do any damage
and tail who were planned to use Ruby
against a Kree invasion you see aliens
Coulson's location faced with no choice
Coulson's old military frenemy Glenn
Tolbert takes under gravitonium and
crushes the Kree unfortunately it also
drives him insane and makes him the
threat to earth survival given the
choice of saving either Coulson or
humanity with a centipede formula Daisy
saves the earth after Daisy Knox Tarbert
into space she returns to Coulson's side
it's too late to save him so he amazedly
off to Tahiti together for a little bit
of happiness before he dies anything
else on your bucket list
just one thing
Peris him but his story isn't over just
yet a duplicate called Sarge is created
when Coulson is sent through time and
space while closing the ref to the fear
dimension Sarge is a combination of
Coulson's memories and that of a fear
dimension entity his mission is to kill
a fear-based creature named ISIL from
infecting anymore well to their Shrike
parasites he teams up with a reluctant
and confusing shield and eventually
realizes his true nature and turns
against his allies ISIL is killed using
Sarge's extra-dimensional sword and Mac
kill Sarge to end the Shrike threat the
end no of course not actually there's
still another version of Coulson that's
because when the krona come hunters then
come to conquer earth a team goes into
the path with a Crona calm life model
decoy base on Coulson programmed to know
everything he missed it just goes to
prove that the only thing better than
one Phil Coulson is several Phil
Coulson's
hey guys check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]